love at first sight crazy people left
and right and justice for TIA
it's time for roses and Rose a you guys
I'm hot under these studio lights and
bachelor in paradise is giving us hot
steamy nights hi everybody last week I
cleanse this week I'm back with my best
friend Rosie and we are talking about
season 5 episode 2 so get your glasses
ready because we have a lot to address
ofso 3 as well we're doing both episodes
well sorry about that guys
4 hours of TV let's dive right in just
like jenna dove right into jordan's arms
and they both tove into the ocean and
her butt wasn't seen but I think it was
there ok I just want to say first of all
you guys don't drink every time somebody
was sweaty on these episodes because oh
my god these people are sweaty the
question is are they sweaty because of
the temperature or because of how hard
they're working it's stirring up the
drama mmm what do you guys think of this
season so far I think it is slaying I
think that people are here to play to
play with each other's minds and hearts
and it is dark and good and dramatic and
I'm here for it I'm loving it let me
know I'm a little bit of it I'm a
passionate Capricorn so watch out
alright in episode 2 we got Jordan and
analyse this shocked me what did you
guys think did you see Jordan and
Annelise having a connection they just
did not seem like a solid pairing to me
one that I thought would have made sense
but of course we all know what happens
so we'll get to it mmm and Kenny and
crystal another pairing I didn't expect
don't drink everytime there's an
unexpected pairing Kenny and crystal go
on a wrestling date and Kenny is so
sweaty mm-hmm and crystal is so normal
do you guys know we're seeing a
different side of crystal than we did
from RE season I like this crystal this
is crystal clear
and then another unexpected pairing and
I have to set my glass down for this
because I am upset Kendall Kendall
Kendall talk to you about some girl you
have grocery store Joe grocery store Joe
the only man to become a breakout star
after mere moments on The Bachelorette
the good-looking kind Midwestern
gainfully employed great hair great
smile grocery store Joe and what does
she do
she makes out with venmo John I did not
see this coming I mean you think
ultimately it was swept under the rug
and nobody really cares and Kendall and
Joe are still hanging out and I will say
I love that mo John he's very sweet but
were you surprised by this Paradise is
so interesting people are just really
going for it even when they don't have
to even when they've already got
somebody Wow Kendall Wow
okay so Colton and Tia we saw Colton
arrive talked to TIA now he's telling
her I feel like I owe it to myself to
explore and figure out what I want with
other people to explore other options
honestly I think at the end of the day
they only hung out for like a weekend
you guys this relationship has really
been blown up into something
so then we get to the rose ceremony and
Colton has screwed things up with Tia
and Tia is into Chris even though she
talks to Chris about Colton and we don't
know what's gonna happen with Cole and I
was sitting here thinking as a fan well
I know he stays around longer I've seen
more footage than this and that would be
so silly to send him home we need the
drama so who comes in our girl Bibiana
here to save the day viviana hasn't been
doing much playing with people's hearts
but she is here to play and she looked
off to the side and my head was
wondering is she looking your producers
and in a surprise move Colton gives
Colton her rose were you guys shocked by
this I did not see this coming
also wills was here for an interview and
spoiler alert wills and Nick were sent
home and wills was frustrated he said
that Bibiana told him she was giving him
her rose Oh
shameless plug check out the interview
it's dark on paradise this season you
guys dark and stormy in the best way
possible the reason why I came here is
to sort of give myself that affirmation
that I can move on Colton continues and
do you guys think Colton wants to be the
bachelor I do I do think he does I'm not
saying that's a bad thing I don't blame
him I just think he does I think the way
he's playing this about keeping his
options open and he's moved on but sort
of not I don't know let me know you
think Becca shows up I did not see this
coming and I didn't need to see it I
have to say
Colton's tears over this whole thing
were a little annoying to me
were they tears I drink every time
Colton was crying without crying the
brink of sight
I wasn't true to who I was gonna happen
I mean everybody
if I was okay I said yeah of course good
I will say maybe he was just frustrated
by the whole situation frustrated with
his own actions I have cried tears of
frustration but I want to pull out of
the frustration station so let's move on
to the next episode episode 3 mmm
transition transition transition anyway
our graphics are great so do not drink
every time some dudes are just laying
around talking in paradise they are
petty this is real
seeing you was the last thing I expected
today so we're we started off again with
this Colton and Becca thing and you guys
I just don't care about it I'm sorry
seeing the conversation between Colton
and Becca I didn't even understand it
she said she was happy she gave him
closure I think she said he needed a
kick in the you-know-what I was like
blown to that did she give him that he
said she did what did she say that gave
him that were you baffled by this did
you feel you got any closure on Colton
and Becca not only did I not feel that I
did get closure but I also didn't need
it okay no thanks mmm
I'm over it we can't keep going back and
forth between Colton and Becca and Tia
it's now we're on the second series for
this romance I'm past it I think I think
I'm ready to open up I really do
whiplash Colton has bounced back all the
guys thought he was gonna leave but he's
not his heart is open hmm new song from
Celine Dion coming in 2019 my heart will
go on - my heart is open anyway anything
can happen
and today the goose is flying high why
does Chris call himself the goose did I
miss this from the premiere that's a
nickname I don't need let me know guys I
guess I missed it Jenna's in paradise
and it's about to get coke
jeanna arrives I like Jenna do you guys
like Jenna I don't think that she got a
fair shake on re-season she's cute and
quirky and she says weird crap that I
love like why did she show up and start
talking to Chris Harrison about how she
was an alien I am an alien legitimately
yeah but a nice happy doing like I'm not
no lasers coming out of my eyes like
you're not trying to take over my soul
being an alien is hard on earth but then
you also have the upper hand she she
said she was an alien because I quote
you can unzip your skin into your
invisible okay hey so Jenna and Jordan
make way more sense to me than Jordan
and Annalise I was here for this yes you
guys get really really whoa than myself
here Jordan said and I quote that Jenna
was the girl version of him but uh well
of course Jordans gonna love the girl
version of him he's Jordan he's just
being Jordan and he always says mmm
horses are you kidding me guys the
horses they go on a date and I will say
why couldn't they get on a horse I don't
know how to get on voices why was that
such a struggle are they short wasn't
one helping them get on that horse and
there's no doubt in my mind that he's
already in love Jordans already in love
do not drink every time somebody talks
about how intense Jordan and Jenna's
connection is Kendall said that she
could tell Jordan was already quote in
love what are we missing the timeline
here they've known each other been
talking to each other for like an hour
right this is wild were you guys
surprised by that did you believe it do
you think Jordan and Jenna are in love
already kinda mean were lying for this
it's a lot I love this season I love it
I love it I love it I love it this is
the kind of ocean I like ocean of wine
from Jordan is that he really genuinely
has feelings for me Annalise is waiting
around while Jordan has gone on a date
with Jenna
another woman and she says that she
expects to have a ring on this finger a
proposal from Jordan by the end of the
season so man we go back to Jordan and
Jenna's date and they are really making
out so much so that they blurt out her
but repeatedly why why what parts affair
will we where we'd seeing that we
weren't supposed to see I just didn't
understand it it's just like it's a but
what like why it's or swimsuit or but I
don't know what don't drink every time
they blur it out
[Music]
your birthday I'll just be fun they were
blaring out so much I spent a lot more
time with Jenna than I have ever spent
with you now wow wow wow if I wasn't
already sitting down I would tell myself
to sit down for this because when Jordan
sits down with Annalise upon returning
from the date oh my god Jordan is always
Jordan and he was Jordan with this
conversation with Annalise you guys he
had no finesse for a man who considers
himself the pensive gentleman he should
have thought more about this
conversation he was just laying it out
for poor Annalise don't drink every time
he said his date with Jenna was quote
fantastic to the woman he had been
dating it was and
but today what happened on that beach
the romantic connection there it just
doesn't happen
never it's gonna be hard for me to catch
us up to what happened today
it was nuts I think that Jena is gonna
go ahead and ride it out and
tomorrow if something happens and you
know like she decides I'm not for her he
literally tells in Elise that she's his
backup plan so just know that like I'm
saving a place for you if something does
happen
he's like I'm saving a place for you as
a person
this was rough and then he goes to
really really healthy you could talk
Jordan the golden underwear might be a
little too tight cutting off the blood
flow to your brain
okay so Annalise definitely has more
trauma and then I became traumatized
David happy birthday no no no you go
away David don't you bring Jenna that
birthday cake that's not a cake well
what is that did you guys think that was
actually a cake let me know it looked
like sort of a pancake how many was
really a cake David all season long on
Beca season was inserting himself into
things with Jordan to cause drama and
have a personality and now he's doing it
again
I don't believe he was really interested
in Jenna he doesn't have anything else
going on don't bring her the cake I
wanted cheers to Jenna because she just
kept eating the cake she didn't care she
was like I don't know I guess she goes
being dramatic but I actually want to
eat this cake pancake thing good for you
I always will to eat a piece of cake mmm
well it's sad I'm just thinking about
that and I can't think of any time my
life they've ever turned on a piece of
cake anyway do they make wine flavored
cake okay Lauren Shh
and Caroline's here I like Caroline I
think she is stunningly beautiful and a
real sweetheart she's just so nervous
but she's just so cute her and John go
on a date and I can see this coupling
because John is the type of guy who is
just a great guy and he is worth a cutie
pie like Caroline who's wonderful I will
say that they go to dinner and they're
talking about why they're in paradise
and Caroline says I just like to find
somebody he like act with it and then
hopefully it can turn into something
more right and John's like be to God
we're so on the same page yeah
everybody's here for that reason that
didn't mean anything to me
you know let's stop talking about the
connections like it's something unique
that we're here to meet someone
your honor in reality show to find love
we all know that's the premise okay
whiplash you believe what what what
blast from the past
Jubilee comes in and she wants to go on
a date with venmo John and she takes him
right away from cuddling with Caroline
Penn much Sean is a player now you guys
and I like it cuz he deserves it cuz
he's a good guy with a lot going on then
we're gonna switch on over to something
else that's troubling Chris and Krystal
another pairing I didn't see coming
yeah I'm not here for Chris tonight you
guys I thought that he'd redeemed
himself on men tell all with that
apology and just owning that he went off
the rails on the Bachelorette but he's
doing it again tonight I think that
Chris is someone who gets wrapped up in
these environments and becomes a
different person so he was so all-in for
Tia he was calling out Colton for not
treating tol and then Chris goes all-in
on crystal thirty seconds after the
conversation with Tia and I want to say
crystal you deserve better
he said quote I don't think I've ever
like kissed a blonde
we're not really flattering you so much
right now crystal that's not flattery
that's not flattery nothing he's saying
to you as flattery he's treating you
like a notch on his belt like a trophy
moment like he wants to say he's kissed
a blonde no no no no no kisses for you
Chris no kisses for Chris's really I
want to make sure you don't get hurt but
then but then then Colton goes to TIA
about Chris so Chris and Colton are just
going back and forth and trying to call
each other out for not treating TIA
right bottom line justice for Tia she
does not deserve this no no no no it's
all too much of a mess TIA remove
yourself from the stress from the whole
situation Chris and Colton are here Tia
you're here take yourself out of it
neither of them no no no no no who do
you guys think - you should be with
Chris Colton
no one none of these guys son I have to
say I'll be interested to see how it all
turns out but I hope it doesn't turn out
with Colton or crisp anything can happen
and today the goose is flying high okay
the last two minutes of Tuesday night's
episode are Chris and Jordan making so
many stupid analogies and metaphors and
about geese just don't drink every time
they said something so dinner is crystal
free using literary questionable the
goose doesn't know what direction he's
gonna fly after a night well I just said
of literary so Paris is a loaf of bread
the roses in your garden so birds are
gonna fall to the goose tonight it's
time to cut the boobs everybody what a
night
bachelor in paradise is starting this
season off right I loved episodes 2 & 3
please let me know what you think and I
love watching with you guys of course
what a great way to finish off the
summer thank you as always for your
comments and thoughts oh man I saw some
arroz Alif but I am overheated and
depleted bye